I think it will be jarring when we see
an interest rate hike because we haven't
had one for some time and then I think
you know people get out the smelling
salts take a sniff and recover because
when we have and when we have that first
hike the Fed has already suggested that
it will be very conservative at the
trajectory of future hikes and so if we
end up with interest rates at half a
percent or even if we went over time in
the near future to one percent against a
growth rate it will only be because the
growth rate is that trend growth or
maybe even higher that will still be
substantially easier financial
conditions than we usually have it's a
funny set of circumstances that makes
interest rates so low while growth is so
while growth is so embedded and that's
because of the uncertainty that that
growth is really truly embedded and the
Fed would rather take a risk on having
rates too soft for longer than run the
risk of giving up all that they've
accomplished and in getting the economy
to where it is now and so they will keep
things easier for a long time you can
also argue that because Congress is so
fragmented and paralyzed we don't have
much of a fiscal policy and the Fed has
no choice but to do some things that it
wasn't really designed for and that I
don't think monetary policy is the right
ways to go about it but if nobody else
is going to do something they feel an
obligation probably right that they have
to do something having said all of that
it does seem to be a lot of job creation
but I don't know any businessperson
that's going to decide to go into a
business or build a building because
interest rates are at point 2 5 vs 2.5 I
mean come on if interest rates and tax
policy are the decision are the guiding
factors in terms of whether an
investment makes sense or not you're
making the wrong investment